hey friends i'm here at my office at uc
san diego and i just recorded an episode
with none other than
sheldon glashow young sheldon old
sheldon winner of the 1979 nobel prize
in
physics he's a towering figure in
physics and a generous gentle soul i had
so much fun with him
i asked him to give a report card about
the state of physics how it's changed
since 1979 when he won his nobel prize
and you won't want to miss
his answer to that question uh you'll be
surprised at the
letter grade he gives to physics and
you'll get a fascinating glimpse into
a very very interesting character who is
going to play a role in my upcoming book
which is coming soon tentatively titled
lessons from laureates and you'll find
out more about that and all the good
stuff
you are going to learn from these
brilliant guests that i'm
that i'm so privileged to have on the
show stick to the end of the episode if
you want to hear
how shelley lost a dollar and 27 years
worth of interest to eric weinstein
you'll also find out aunt shelley's
answer to the question that i asked him
which i considered the most important
question i've ever asked a guest on my
show
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
welcome everybody to this episode of the
into the impossible podcast i am your
fearful host brian keating co-director
of the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
and today we have a very special guest
who is not only
a uh really a you know an icon in the
field of physics of all different
varieties
but also a huge science fiction fan and
i hope to
discuss with my guest sheldon glashow
emeritus professor at harvard and
currently
the metcalf professor of mathematics and
physics at boston university
oh no i'm also retired from that one oh
you are okay so do you get
two two american salaries
very good in 1961 uh sheldon glashow
extended the lecture week unification
models due to schwinger his phd advisor
who we'll get into today and he did so
by including a neutral current that
operated at
short ranges we'll talk about that the z
naught
and the symmetry that resulted uh was
originally
uh depicted as su 2 cross u1 we'll talk
about what that means
and where things go uh from here in
physics perhaps extending if
if shelley has time to su5 and beyond
we'll
we'll keep it as technical as shelley's
willing to go i've got a lot of
questions
of my own and most importantly i want to
just
uh thank you for coming on the into the
impossible podcast where we talk about
all sorts of matters not just physics
but this is sort of nobel
prize week where you have on barry
barish uh tomorrow
and we had on adam reese last week
and uh next week we'll have harry is
tomorrow
barry's on the show tomorrow he's
recording a second episode
and we also have uh some of your friends
and and uh acolytes
that you inspired people like frank
wilcheck are coming on
as well as cameron baffa and we've had
on
uh some really spectacular guests
yesterday we had on lenny suskind
who has a deep connection to shelly and
i wanted to start there
uh because one of the things that
strikes me about your book which we'll
talk a lot about
interactions just a lovely book it's now
about 32 years old
hard to believe but i remember seeing
this book when it came out
and only finished it a couple hours ago
but but it was well worth it and it's
still timely as ever and i want to get
into that including
this very fascinating score card almost
a report card
for physics that you gave as an
assignment in 1988
when this book first came out and i want
to ask you
what kind of grade both theoretical
particle physics string
theory and my field of experimental
cosmology
what kind of grade we would be getting
against these very difficult challenging
homework assignments that you gave the
field back in 1988 but first
let's start with your uh with with your
interactions with lenny suskind who was
on the show yesterday
and lenny said to give regards to shelly
and say how's the plumbing job holding
up in your 50 year old house in
brookline massachusetts
yeah he was here and uh because we
shared the fact that uh that
his father and my father were both in
the plumbing profession
actually my father employed plumbers and
uh
he had a little plumbing concern on 1622
amsterdam avenue in new york
which amazingly enough still exists
uh although my father died in 1962
and had sold the company to his foreman
uh or given it to him effectively in uh
in the 1950s but the white trucks that
patrol new york are called the el
glashow and company
and they're still there with the same
name as my father always said
reputation is very important yes his
reputation lives on
as a plumber mine does not
so i had some plumbing problem that that
i had to call on a real plumber to fix
actually i didn't pay this particular
plumber
uh at another occasion though it was a
christmas eve
and we had a flood in our bathroom
and it was a mess so i turned off the
water in the house
and i dredged up my old memories of how
to wipe a joint
which is an old way of fixing a pipe
when you have a broken pipe is you
take some molten lead and pour it around
and wrap it with
your hand and a glove you sort of
wrapped the joint with
melted lead and it worked and it also
has lasted for now something like 47
years
so i too can still plumb a bit
uh you missed your calling potentially
as an experimentalist
there's a lot of piping and tubing
involved in the ligo experiment i'll be
talking with barry about
tomorrow uh the ligo experiment being a
four kilometer
evacuated plumbing pipe in uh louisiana
and washington
so maybe you could have uh maybe can
have a second career who knows following
in the family tradition but uh
the other thing you share in common with
lenny of course is that you both
attended
uh not only cornell but uh the bronx uh
bronx science which is uh
has more nobel laureate alumni than some
countries on earth
and i want to first start one of them
actually
yeah and that's uh really a phenomenal
record of course
you won the nobel prize in 1979
and we'll talk about that in the effect
that it had um
but first you know your father really
plays a big role
in this in this podcast and it reminds
me of a of a conversation with jim
simons
uh who is from the boston area not from
the new york area but he currently lives
there
and he told me once that you know
plumbers don't get enough uh respect and
attention
in fact once he had to call a plumber
for a late night repair
uh and he called the plumber the plumber
comes over and
uh 15 minutes of work he says that'll be
uh that'll be 400
and jim says you know 400 what would you
do i'm a hedge fund manager
you know i i make barely 3 200 an hour
you work for 15 minutes that's 3 200 an
hour and uh the plumber says to jim
simons
uh oh yeah you make 3 200 that's what i
used to make when i was a hedge fund
manager
so uh sometimes uh we we should not
overlook the uh the importance of
plumbing
but your father plays a big role and and
of course he passed away and you said
1962 which is
really a year after your really uh
eventual nobel prize winning discovery
what do you think he would have made of
the festivities and kind of the
the the level that you ascended to uh in
science would he have appreciated it he
played such a big role in your life as
you described
oh yes he would certainly have
appreciated he was
himself frustrated uh
because he never managed to go to
college or at least complete college he
started in at
cooper union but never quite had the
time
with a young family to feed that he
had to do his plumbing so uh yeah he
would
he would have been very appreciative
that he lived
uh but unfortunately i lost him he he
had many stories to tell
about plumbing one of which i will tell
you yes he came back saying well one day
he was
uh called on by some woman in a
luxury apartment in fifth avenue and she
uh called him and said i would like you
to
install a bidet in my apartment
and he said of course be gay i will
certainly do that let's make an
appointment
uh and which he did in the future
because he had no idea of what a bidet
might be
uh being a russian immigrant and he just
didn't have
experience with such things so he asked
his friends and finally
was able to find at the day and
installed it the
woman was very satisfied and maybe she
got 400
for that yes it's uh you never know how
valuable they are until you need them
uh but i want to uh talk a little bit
more about
the role that collaboration played in
your life uh this book
in really contradiction to uh lenny's
book
my black hole war with stephen hawking
that we discussed on the podcast
um you know he speaks of collaboration
too but it's almost in the sense of
of wanting to have a rival not a nemesis
like an evil villain
but to have someone that you are trying
to always out do
and i see you know you talk about your
lifelong friendships
with stephen weinberg and and with
others as well
as um uh recounted throughout and your
almost
paternal you know father-son
relationship with schwinger
uh i sense very little of adversarial or
nemesis
content in this book and and i wonder
you know
is there is there a role for sort of a
rival as a theoretical physicist
that uh we often have it in experiment
we're we're trying not to get scooped
we're trying not to get beaten by other
experiments does having a rival in
theoretical physics is that
anathema to that practice or is it
something that could be healthy if used
properly
no i've not had uh much experience
with rivals in theoretical physics uh
it's always been for me a cooperative
endeavor uh for example with steve
weinberg
we of course not only went to high
school together but we went to college
together as well
and were both professors at uh at the
university of california
for a few years together we wrote a
couple of
excellent papers uh at least two maybe
three
uh then we we did uh
fall apart for a while we had our
differences for reasons which are not
related to physics
uh but uh that's the closest
i had i i would have to i wouldn't call
him a rival i'd
suggest someone in physics with whom i
had
personal differences uh no
it's been cooperative all the way i
think for example of my long-term
relationship with
sydney coleman who by the way
was a much more avid science fiction
he even published science fiction
criticism he had a
partial owner of the publishing company
advent publishers
uh no or i have my minor claim is in
high school
i was one of the editors
of the first science fiction high school
fan scene
but that was uh as close as i came to
publishing science fiction
so stay with what with sydney i
had my first uh interesting
papers written we were inspired
by murray gilman's eight-fold way theory
so we showed how you can do things with
three by three matrices that others used
eight by eight matrices i
felt we felt very confident about that
and
we had our only eponymous
formula the coleman glacial formula
which was once interesting is sort of
lost interest today
uh anyway then we came back sydney and i
went our own ways and
did different things for many many years
and just before he
retired from harvard is
already showing symptoms of the disease
that would eventually kill them
we wrote a series of papers on testing
testing einstein's special theory of
relativity
and these were were great so here's a
a man that i collaborated with at the
very beginning of his career
and at the very end of his career uh
but cooperative always and speaking of
science fiction uh if i recall correctly
you're related to
to this gentleman uh this is carl sagan
uh in finger puppet form uh we have to
get you a finger puppet version i i have
one of him i have one of
galileo galilei and one of einstein
but of course carl sagan wrote science
fiction proper
hard science fiction as well as being a
foremost
you know exponent of of you know science
non-fiction
can you talk a little bit about uh well
first of all how you are related to
our uh the late great carl sagan whose
widow has been on my podcast as well as
his daughter
sasha sagan she's a writer in her own
right so the apple did not fall from the
cosmic apple tree
uh so can you talk about the uh the
impact of science fiction on you and and
how
it may have influenced you maybe not to
take the career path that you did take
uh well yes of course carl
comes rather later in my career than
science fiction
uh carl was married to well
my wife has had three sisters
and one of those sisters uh lynn
margulies
uh was the first wife of
carl sagan in fact it was
the greatest contribution carl sagan
made to science
was to get lynn who was a history or a
literature major
uh to switch to biology and she became
uh very well known in biology
uh with a a rather mixed reputation for
a while because
some people thought that the things that
she was doing were
quite crazy uh they became textbook
accomplishments and at the end of her
life she was
widely acclaimed as uh as a very
fine biologist anyway that was lynn and
uh
that was how i knew uh carl
carl came by once to harvard
uh this was he was already at cornell
he was uh doing research on
on whether there could be
life on mars or something like that he
ran
into a mathematical problem that he
couldn't solve so he asked sydney
to solve it for him which he did it was
uh
essentially trivial uh just like lynn
was not very talented
mathematically nor was nor was carl
anyway the problem solved carl wrote a
paper and then sydney was absolutely
flabbergasted to discover that he had
written a paper with carl
on the possibility of life on mars
that's every uh science fiction fan's
dream is to inadvertently discover some
possibility for life on mars
yeah no science fiction was an important
part of my life when i was
uh like say 12 13 14.
i uh read astounding science fiction
religiously from uh more or less 1944
to the 1960.
uh well i don't know if it lasted that
long but
that was uh yes it was very important
for example
there was a column in astounding science
fiction called brass
tax which talked about science
and it was there that i learned about
the possibility of atomic bombs
before the explosions that took place in
japan
uh yes i can say that science fiction
got me
to some extent got me into science my
brothers
were also responsible in various
measures
but science fiction played a significant
role
and i still appreciate it i will
occasionally read
science fiction but not that often right
yeah i always uh find the the attraction
and kind of the limited time available
to want to understand more about science
non-fiction
while i while i can and hopefully can
make some contributions
um i want to talk about the role of
teachers in your life
you speak very um in very glowing terms
obviously about schwinger
uh and and and really about his
generosity
of time of attention you know mentoring
a dozen students at once at one point
including you and i i just you know i'm
an experimentalist the most students
i've ever had is about six
and that's even kind of impossible to
imagine uh
what was he like as a teacher as a
mentor um
as a and not just as a physicist
well yes he spent a lot of time with uh
by having 12 or 13 students at a time
but a corollary is that he didn't spend
very much time with
any one student i
did not get to speak with him much about
my thesis
the when i and my friends
uh invaded his office to get these
subjects
uh he i was at the end of the line so he
gave me something that was uh
rather speculative he's more or less
said go and unify a weak and
electromagnetic
interactions but i had no idea how to do
that
but i i he wouldn't he didn't have a
great deal of assistance to give me
consequently i didn't manage to get very
far uh
either i did a few things which
convinced me and perhaps convinced
julian that
that there was a possibility
possible road toward a unified theory of
weak and electromagnetic interactions
but i had not found that road
he didn't he was a very kind man he
would
on several occasions bring me to his
home where his wife would
entertain us serve a very nice dinner
but altogether perhaps during my college
career
i aside from having lunches where we
didn't discuss
science i must have spent no more than
two hours with him
for advice and encouragement oh wow
that's uh that's a pretty uh
impressively short amount of time i'm
going to tell that to my students who
complain about me
spending that much time with them per
week
uh i want to talk also about the role of
ego
in science and whether or not it is um
not only pernicious as it certainly can
be but
but can lead to this you know level of
confidence
as well to to pursue ideas even when
they're
likely to be wrong uh you you don't
strike me as a person from the the
you know what i've what i've observed
and you're very can the book is
hilarious um
you know and and i think it should be
required reading a mentoring a young
a young student actually he's a young
child of uh
of one of your a person that you made a
bet with eric weinstein
you made apparently made a dollar bet he
was telling me
that was paid off 27 years later but not
with
interest so maybe we'll get into that
but anyway his son zev is quite
brilliant
and i've assigned his son zev who i'm
mentoring for
uh for some research projects he's 15
years old i've assigned him to read
interactions
because it's so good at explaining what
was known
in you know as of 1988 and depressingly
there's only a few things that have been
added to this canon but the one thing
that strikes me is how honest
how hilarious how um uh just how
magnanimous you are in your writing and
i think it's so commendable it makes it
very easy to read very easy to
understand and yet i suspect there is a
role of ego in your life
to really do things and have a courage
to pursue things can you say
you know the role that confidence if you
will plays in in theoretical physics
uh the role of ego and uh
it's hard to address that subject let
let me
let me say rather that that
what i found found
doing science to be a lot of fun
i began doing real science
perhaps as a graduate student i wrote a
paper with an experimental
physicist that at that time it wasn't a
very good paper but it got me in the
game
uh the when i went off to copenhagen
after uh completing my studies with
julian schwinger
uh that was the neil spohr institute
i spent two years there on and off
sharing the time at cern
but what i discovered at
copenhagen was a a plethora of
graduate students of postgrad rather of
postgrad
postdoctoral students from many
countries from
china from russia from japan from
eastern european countries close friends
i
made with a polish scientist a
czech scientist italian etc etc andrew
wrote a paper with uh
papers with them papers with with
norwegian scientists
uh swedish scientists what i realized is
that their
cooperation is the name of the game and
when i uh went while at copenhagen it
was at copenhagen by the way in the
spring of 1960
that i had the idea
of the su 2 cross u1 theory and wrote
the paper in
in 1960 sent it into a journal called
nuclear physics
which takes its time about publication
so
although i submitted it in the spring
of 1960 it was published in uh
in 1961. so i it's really in 1960 that i
did that work
question of ego there it is uh but
the the next great
moment in my life was meeting sydney
coman
as a postdoc at caltech uh
things were so different than in physics
i was hopping having a ball
traveling between my lady friend in
geneva and my lady friend
in copenhagen and stopping in
germa in germany typically on the way
and picking up a couple hundred dollars
for giving a talk
uh i had a uh and enabling me for
example to buy a tr3
there so i could commute more easily and
more rapidly
i was having so much fun uh
which is the name of the game as far as
i'm concerned in science and it's always
been that way
ever since science is fun the science i
did with
uh johnny leopolus which led to the uh
glacially leopolis miami
paper which which i'm very proud emerged
in part in on the beaches of mexico
while we were
both participating in some summer school
uh swimming around in the ocean and he
was a
also a scuba diver uh as well uh
we came upon our ideas
it was it was fun all the way along and
one of the things i enjoyed
most about my career in science is there
was usually
a time when i knew something that
my peers did not that is to say when
uh at the time that murray introduced uh
su-3 as flavor s23 the eightfold way
it was obviously correct uh in
my opinion and in in sydney's opinion
uh we knew that this theory was right
they didn't
so we talked all over the world in fact
lectured about this the wonderful theory
that had to be true
and sure enough three years after it was
invented it was
proven to be true by the work of my
experimental friend nick samios
at brookhaven lab finding the uh
the uh whatever the omega minus particle
the missing particle
uh so it's always been fun and uh
when we when i suggested the uh
my biggest embarrassment personal
embarrassment was
this that when in 1964
i returned to copenhagen uh
i i worked with
james bjorklane and we published a paper
which
introduced the idea of the charmed quark
including naming the damn thing
and i then promptly forgot about that
work
at the time that we invented it i didn't
realize that it was an essential step
in expanding the electro week theory
that i had
previously worked on uh to make it uh
apply to nuclear matter as well as to
leptons
the theory that i talked about and that
steve weinberg talked about was the
theory of leptons
and uh i i simply didn't recognize that
that this
this was the key to it all until i
collaborated with
mayani and ilviopoulos and we realized
that
the charm the charm cork could realize
it
it's its name when we named it uh i
named it randomly charm i don't know why
i picked that word
but charm it was it was a a thing that
averted evil the evil being the
strangeness changing neutral currents
that don't exist
so you get you uh explain that and
yeah yeah how charm works it's uh
uh rather rather charming and you also
talk about a um
uh ileopolis and you recruited him right
uh you were
basically one of the uh people
responsible i also recruited
uh alvaro de rujola who also
was a very important participant in my
research career i was not the there was
the department that chose uh
howard georgia but he also turned out to
be a very
important ingredient in my career i
think i've written
over 30 papers uh with with each of
those people
if you're liking this video so far make
sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell
i put out videos at least once a week
and i'm here to show the human side of
scientists
despite the stereotypes we are human
beings my mission is to increase
curiosity
and engage a multiverse of magnificent
minds i also do subscriber only
giveaways frequently
and i give away copies of books by my
guests and other cool things like signed
papers by nobel prize
winners and so forth so don't miss out
on that subscribe and hit the
notification bell
talk about recognizing you know traits
or
you know potential greatness in a young
scientist
how how did you approach it was it more
just you had a connection or
are there metrics are there quantitative
um
you know tracers that be speak of the
potential of a future young colleague
well our choice of post docs was
when i was at harvard was very uh
democratic
so basically we discussed the matter
and uh and came upon our our favorite
choices
uh we were lucky
we hit upon the right people at the
right time i don't
i can't a posteriori
explain why we had to write post-docs
but
throughout my career i and my friends
uh picked a long series of wonderful
uh founders to join us
and that um the the characteristic that
really
you know strikes me in here is one of
collaboration
and congeniality and i wonder you know
how connected you are to it in your
emeritus phase but one of the biggest
blows to
physics due to covet aside from the
awful human toll it's taken and tragic
at that but
it's the lack of in-person gatherings of
conferences
you talk of you know conference or
meeting or sabbatical
or travel on almost every page of this
book
and it seems to me there might be some
permanent damage due to physics
at least for some younger generation of
physicists at least i got to participate
in it but i
i feel uh very uh it's very unfortunate
that young physicists are not
experiencing
the types of gatherings that you spoke
about in this book and
uh the role of collaboration looms large
in this book there's there's very little
i did this i did this it's always
how when this fortuitous serendipitous
partnership with somebody
because of a sabbatical uh you know or
because of a conference held somewhere
led to a great paper and a great result
so i feel
physics has lost that and it's not clear
when it's coming back all the all our
conferences are remote like this
yeah then i last this year i would i was
supposed to be
in italy i was supposed to be in for
reasons of physics i was supposed to be
a
judge for a a prize in
spain which had to take place remotely i
was supposed to be in china on several
occasions
all of these things had been canceled
not to speak with vacations in mexico
and as such so uh yes there's no
question that
cobit has had a terrible effect
but and continues to just today for
example the schools in
new york city were announced to close
beginning tomorrow or something very
soon yeah
yeah we've uh you know even in southern
california have been
quite uh quite afflicted by it all our
public schools have been closed
for a very not
[Music]
the usual available experience they're
making the best of it and they're going
to some
physical classes but many of the classes
are remote
yeah it doesn't say um
i want to uh ask just getting back to
these different
uh personalities that you uh you know
interacted with
you talk in the book uh about um
some people that you know for example um
schwinger you point out uh how
how he was um you know how his
personality lent it lent itself it was
sort of a coolness about him a distance
about him
i see other people nowadays you know um
that
that can be really challenging the
orthodoxy
of of standard standard concepts in
physics as i think you did i mean you
were one of the early
you know um opponent i want to say
opponents but but
uh conscientious objectors to string
theory and and certainly i want to get
into that
um but it also takes a certain amount of
courage and i wonder in an age of social
media
which i i don't think you have a twitter
account that i know about
no i don't uh but you know the ideas
that be
that are originally tentative um might
that would have seen the light of day
and maybe gotten a little bit more
nourishment
in previous generations now because of
twitter instantaneous you know you can
basically
almost humiliate somebody's idea long
before
it gets out of the infant mortality
stage and i wonder
you know if if you've observed anything
negative in the trend i mean it's not
only
you know positive benefits of technology
getting better and better
but are there negatives to that impede
scientific progress especially in high
energy or particle physics that you've
observed
uh i'm not a fancier of of the social
media
in any respect uh but
i don't i i can speak of many
of deleterious effects that the social
media may have had but not
upon the progress of science i don't see
that there's
been that people come up with theories
and spread them on social media
and and have them take over no that
doesn't happen
uh fortunately
we have course we have our own social
medium uh which is
the uh distribution of
research uh on the web yes uh but
on what's called the archive now that is
a marvelous development of my
uh my physicist friend uh paul what's
his name
spark against practice and has
revolutionized the progress of physics
because it's enabled people
in uh countries with in poorer countries
to be able to access what's going on
every day they have uh deposited in
their mailbox the latest articles that
have been written
and it's open and accessible and free to
all the world
so that's massively encouraged
science worldwide science throughout the
world
and the ability to teach and to
disseminate lectures
from harvard from mit from uc san diego
uh in fact i want to bring you uh
greetings from
my friend professor stefan alexander who
is the uh president of the national
society of black physicists
and he calls you one of your one of his
heroes he's a professor at brown
university now
and uh he you taught at a summer school
i guess that he attended as a young
man of only 15 years old and nowadays
that such a thing could be done on the
internet and i want to hearken to page
167 in interactions you talk about
the the dual function of the professor
it's to teach
but also to do research but actually
teaching
can improve your research in fact you
say the best
researchers in some countries such as
the soviet union
the best researchers are secreted in
research institutions where they do not
teach
and the university professors are not
encouraged to do research
i found that ironic because one of my
friends is
russian and he says that if you
translate the word scientist
from russian to english it basically
means someone who was taught
it means a person who was educated or
it's taught a
that's what it means to be a scientist
why do you think of
teaching as sort of a secret tool or a
secret weapon of the west at least in
terms of
improving your research
well it's the american tradition and the
british tradition
that researchers are teachers
almost always it is not necessarily true
in countries like germany
where uh there have been many uh a great
deal of research has
done at research institutes that do not
teach
germany has not suffered terribly from
from this procedure that i think that
i think teaching and research go
together neatly but
they don't have to they can be separated
and i probably would have done even more
research had i not
the responsibilities of teaching but i
probably wouldn't have been as happy
because seeing how these kids learn
when they do which isn't always is is
very beautiful
and i've had some wonderful uh taught
some wonderful students
and that's been an
essential part of my life but i don't
think it was a key
to uh to the researchers i i've done
i don't think it's that essential right
and
have done quite well scientifically
they're segregating their their
scientists and their futures
that's right yeah and you talk a lot
about that including the serendipitous
effect of a delayed visa
to go to the soviet union back in 1961
or so right that led you to go to
copenhagen
that then as you just said i want to
talk about the role of serendipity
um you you you talk candidly about uh
you know the nobel prize and and the
role that it's had in your life and the
ceremony even i want to get into that
later
but you talk about missing out basically
i mean it wasn't known
that it was going to receive the nobel
prize in 1988 when you wrote
interactions
but you talk about missing out just
barely on the higgs you know discovery
or prediction
with um and we had on the show recently
i had on carl hagen
uh who has collaborated with my late
professor jerry garalnick at brown
university where i went to graduate
school
and the two of them um you know played
an enormous role in the
prediction uh i wonder can you take us
back to that time
and you know in terms of like
significance yes you didn't
your name isn't included typically
amongst the seven or eight
co-discoverers of it but it's clear you
had you were on the track and how does
it feel
first of all to to um to come up to make
a discovery like the lecture week
unification or you know ssu
su 2 cross u1 etc how does it feel to
make a discovery like that
know you're the first person on earth
but know that someone else is probably
breathing down your neck as did happen
in the case of the higgs poso ah
well let me you ask about that
the uh i was at cern at the time that
jeffrey goldstone
was talking about spontaneous
symmetry breaking in the context of
relativistic quantum field theory
and uh then again uh the year after
that i he was in
scotland with me at this famous summer
school
where higgs was also present
and we had wonderful discussions about
the
possibility of electoral week
unification
the possibility of using
engaged bosons using gang mills theories
to describe the weak interactions but
the peter did not really participate
much in these discussions because he was
the wine steward he had to
uh take into account the fact that we
were serving
hungarian wines and at a nato nato
meeting and
uh this he wanted to keep this a bit
under the table
it wasn't quite under the table it was
in a grandfather's clock that we stored
a broken grandfather's block that we
stored our
hungarian wines uh so he wasn't part of
the
discussions and we if had he been with
us
uh he would work with
uh with i'm sure with jeffrey goldstone
and they would have come upon
the the ideas that became those of pigs
and company
later on uh this is just a year before
the higgs did his thing and so did
hagen and the other five people who have
been responsible for the creation of the
eggs mechanism
now that was a discovery that i i would
never have made that discovery uh
because i was not so much up on the
details of the
formal theory but it could certainly
have been done by
and should jeffrey goldstone done by
joshua goldstone uh
earlier but whatever
yes all right you can't you can't win
them all at least when it comes to nobel
prizes
um i want to talk about uh about where
we are
in in physics and whether or not this
influence
which i would say you know you were a
prime
uh you know responsible party for which
is
kind of coming up with something so
beautiful it almost can't be wrong
and i'm speaking about unification and
ever since you know maxwell and even
unification of heat and thermodynamics
and statistical mechanics as a form of
unification
all these great discoveries in some way
that we think about gravity
and unification of curvature um of
space-time they they seem to
you know have beautiful elements to them
and i wonder
you know are we are we reaching the end
of the line
it's hard to argue that string theory
isn't beautiful in a certain sense
but um is there sort of a road too far
that
that beauty is no longer capable of
providing
guidance uh if it ever was so i guess
the question is um
are we too overwhelmed as fred hoyle
used to say
with the notion of beauty in our
equations
uh i don't think so i think i would
follow the tradition that einstein of
einstein and
others for uh advocating
elegance and beauty that of paul dirac
was in that tradition
as well uh you know i don't think we're
done with it at all
i anticipate there will be future
discoveries and
and future uh
even more beautiful uh synthesis
will take place in physics uh we need to
know so much
uh what i'm afraid that covet will have
another
uh disastrous effect on science and that
has to do
with the funding of useless research
because
much of the research that we've been
talking about is in fact
useless the higgs bosons have no
practical purpose
k-mesons strange particles which work
right no still have no application and
would never will
and many of the things we do per se
are useless uh certainly the work
that ligo has been doing the wonderful
discoveries that
they have made the opening up of a new
form of astronomy
will have no direct impact on our lives
except the appreciation that we are
understanding the world a little bit
better each day
uh there'll be much more we have so many
mysteries and
and the question is the funding uh
we've not the the american government
traditionally has been generous but no
not overly generous with respect to
science and the same is true
in europe and in japan but
will we continue to fund these forms of
useless science of astronomy
astrophysics space science
and particle physics uh
it will seem perhaps justifiably to the
people of america that more money should
be spent on biology
more money should be spent on on
the means to deal with not only this
uh epidemic this pandemic but the many
pandemics that will come in the future
because we do understand that
that as people travel more and more
and we investigate
odd corners of the world we bring back
odd diseases
and there are many more diseases that
will come in many more
pandemics much research is necessary to
deal with this so we might
encounter a disease that's even worse
than what we have now
however bad it may seem at the moment so
uh money is going to be redirected to
for
toward uh climate change
toward other towards toward pandemics
and toward other threats to
human society will there be any left
over for doing the kinds of research
that we
need to do and that that i don't know
will there be a next accelerator which
is
not all that expensive but uh but it is
costly it is tens of billions of dollars
will that money appear will the chinese
build such a machine
will the europeans build such a machine
the americans have already said they
would not
and what about the value of such a
machine irrespective of who
pays for it um when it's not clear
uh first of all if there is a natural
target for such a machine
aside from bigger is better which i find
that argument falls flat uh in the case
of the
superconducting super collider and in
the case of the lhc
at least the targets were clear uh and
that there was this missing piece that
you talked about back in 1988
that was obvious not low hanging in the
sense that it was easy
but that it couldn't be otherwise in the
opinions of many people
uh that the higgs had to exist and then
had to have roughly bounded
mass range that was accessible
i think to you know i've heard pitches
for the future circular collider that
will go back to the big bang or we're
not going to get anywhere close to
say the grand unified epoch that you you
know really ushered in this notion of
grand unification we'll get to that in a
second
how would you proceed if you're this you
know assuming you took your nobel prize
winnings and put it all in bitcoin
and now you're worth trillions of
dollars still would you fund such a
a future circular collider which by the
way they always tell you the price tag
to build a project but from an
experimentalist
we always double it for two reasons one
you have to operate the darn thing
you can't just build a battleship or
aircraft carrier and just there it is
now we're not going to use it it's about
10
per year so in a decade uh you spend you
know you double the cost to operate it
but not only that when there's no clear
target for the future circular collider
as cool as it is and i don't want to
rain on the
on the parade or the income stream of my
experimental particle physics colleagues
but how would you deal with it
uh knowing that you know bigger is
better but there's no natural target for
such a machine what would you do
well first of all yes the uh the higgs
boson cost us about uh
20 billion dollars if you take into
account the uh the
operation of the machine for 10 or 20
years
for sure uh that may be a low ball
estimate in fact
so things do get expensive i can say
what else would you want to do with your
money of course but
there are many answers to that uh
the my hope is that
the theorists will come to the rescue
the there is one question
which i think is the central one of the
central questions of
particle physics which is not often
discussed
and the question is is there anything
else
to observe beyond the standard model
there's many reasons to believe that
there should be things
but not there's no specific there was a
specific theory once upon a time there
was the
supersymmetry which was a nice target
and
the target was uh dealt with properly
and simple symmetry as
constituted as originally invented is
certainly
excluded just as grand unification as
originally
uh configured has been proven to be
wrong
is that sorry shelly sorry to interrupt
but i mean my understanding is
grandification we are not
adequately um energetic enough to test
grain unification if it occurs a 10 to
the 16 ged
we might not have any alternative other
than the cosmic frontier
uh why do you say that that gut well
maybe you said as
originally constituted but would you say
that still it
grant unification is as sort of ruled
out the way that super symmetry is
well uh supersymmetry at low energy is
certainly ruled out sure yes
symmetry was introduced for specific
purposes
and had acquired other specific purposes
such as the explanation of dark matter
and everything looked very neat
except it doesn't lie in that energy
domain
it may lie at some other energy domain
of course
but it would no longer uh no longer do
what it was supposed to do so that
you can still call it supersymmetry uh
but yes supersymmetry as introduced uh
failed and uh certainly the
expectation was that the proton lifetime
would be 10 to the 29th years and that's
been
certainly excluded it's now certainly
more than 10 to the 30 or 31 years
there is no specific target and that's
again comes back to the central question
is there anything else up there uh
none of these theories uh tell us
whether there is something there
least of all strengther they they
are not able to suggest whether there is
something that
could be found at the next accelerator
we've never found
well i still have hopes that the large
hadron collider
will find something interesting i am
confident that the superconducting
supercollider had it not been shot down
unwisely by congress uh would have found
the higgs at
a much less cost than the eventual cost
and would have pushed us to the energies
where
i would hope there would be something
more energies comparable to what would
be achieved at the
chinese machines and the and the cern
machine that are mere
pipe dreams at the moment and but just
getting back thank you for that and
getting back to why you say that
grand unification is sort of excluded
or analogous to low energy
super symmetry being excluded why do you
say that about grand unification as well
well there's no specific target again
it's uh
i say that the original
formulation of supersymmetry had a
very specific purpose in mind and it was
worth
uh looking for super symmetric particles
and
uh they didn't find them and they pushed
it's not they might
it's quite conceivable that that even
the
large hadron collider will produce
evidence for supersymmetry at some point
but it won't be the supersymmetry that
we imagined and the same is true
of ground unification the grand
unification scale
could be higher than 10 to the 16th gev
we have no
a way of being sure whether there is
such a unification skill
i would i support uh
again would you support building uh what
is it called hyper
the the ten times larger proton decay
experiment and now remember we've been
looking
with the current device for over 10
years
and finding nothing and that's telling
us that
the new machine the new detector if it
were
if it existed would not have no chance
of finding proton decay for the first
year of its operation
right not even an indication of it i
find it hard to justify
instruments that have only uh a single
use case in other words i
even though i you know helped to create
this experiment called bicep that was
looking for
inflationary generated primordial
gravitational waves
uh which some hailed as potentially a
harbinger
and an impermature of grand unification
maybe we can get into that
it has other uh it has other abilities
in addition to
just detecting b modes as if that's not
enough because a
inflation may not have happened as you
say grand unification may not have
happened i think we
we know a lot more about the energetics
of of you know of
of unification than we do about you know
10 to the minus
36 seconds after uh the big bang
singularity perhaps
so uh you know i would not spend my
money on it if i had
infinite resources potentially maybe i
would but in a finite resource planet
unless there are multiple cases and yes
there are other things that have come
out of the
out of um the lhc but clearly the higgs
is kind of
it's on their masthead it's what you see
it's it's uh
you know the reason that uh that at
least initially
people were saying yeah we spent 10
billion dollars to win a nobel prize
uh for for this discovery but um i want
to talk about
you know kind of the progress if that's
the the right word it's funny because
you you mentioned congress
and remind me of an old joke like what's
the opposite of pro when someone says
i'll tell you the pros what's the
opposite of
of pro and the answer is khan and then
you say well then what's the opposite of
progress
it must be congress and uh that's a dig
at our
our lawmakers in the great city of
washington dc
but i want to talk about the lack or
perhaps you know
maybe i'm overstating your case here um
you you give
kind of a scorecard of where things
could be
going in the in the future back in 1988
when you wrote this book and presumably
you wrote it in 87
88 it does have a description of
supernova 1987a
which is obviously another serendipitous
discovery
but you have a list of i think nine
things and i want to go over them with
you if you'll
indulge me shelley because it's not so
often that we get to chat
and uh i think this is this is such a
wonderful thing for young people to
think about
what did yeah what did an eminent you
know scientists think about the big
picture questions because a lot of what
i do is ask people
what would you advise young sheldon you
know to use a name of a current hit tv
show
what would you advise young sheldon to
work on so back in 1988 you said
first question why are there so many
basic particles
do you think we have an answer to that
question in the intervening 32
okay so that's an f i'm gonna i'm gonna
make the score card i'll publish the
score card
remember the num i it depends on what
you think the number is i don't remember
what the number was
back then but today uh it's
down to a couple dozen yes yeah well
there's sev
what seven seven yeah 17 elementary
particles including the higgs the
neutrinos they're anti the quarks why
are there so many free parameters
and i guess this is like coupling
constants do you think we've
approached a rationale for the number
the proliferation of coupling constants
or frequent answers to those questions
one minute none so that's two fs um
how do we include gravity in the picture
of um
of high-energy particle interactions
well the string theorists think that
they have an answer to that question but
unfortunately their string theory
doesn't overlap very much with the
kind of physics that interests me and
would you say that the failure to
observe super symmetry
and its concomitant relationship to
string theory is sort of
a significant strike against string
theory or would you certainly
not no theory makes no mention of where
supersymmetry should live
so that no that's not that in no way
would that
should that be construed as evidence
against winter
interesting so if god han i know you
don't believe in god but if a god handed
you a paper and said there is
super symmetry is completely excluded
all energy skills
would that cast any doubt on the
legitimacy of string theory
uh i i'm not quite that that is too
hypothetical
okay fair enough uh yep so you say how
to so i'll give gravity included in the
standard model i'll give that a
tentative c i'll give it a c for now
we don't we don't grade inflate unlike
you guys at harvard and
and bu um just kidding so why are there
three fermion families
that's a big question why are there
three
i don't know those are
the kinds of questions i would like to
have answers to
do you think people are are thinking
about these questions are they thinking
about like oh well this
you know 17th order correction and a
fineman diagram
17 order corrections are not my style
but
uh the uh i would love to
know why there are three families of
cloaks and leptons
uh if and i would like to know if they
are
as identical to one another as we
believe
could there be something missing in our
plans
and i'm still hoping for an outrageous
discovery from the
large hadron collider it could be for
example the
discovery of a new particle that decays
into a pair of leptons with the same
charge
or something like that which just
doesn't fit into the picture at all
and that would lead us to perhaps uh a
new direction and that brings up the
next question
uh why are the charges of the fermions
the way they are
and i would assume based on what you
just said we
don't have much more clarity model
constrains them
through a very high degree
so for example the uh the integer
character of electric charge the fact
that the electric charge and the proton
charge
are alike aside from the fact that that
had to be if life
uh could possibly exist uh that is
in incorporated within the standard
model we understand that
and why do very large numbers appear
to play a fundamental role in our theory
and you say
dirac emphasized the philosophical view
that all numbers that are truly
fundamental to physics or mathematics
like pi
or the number of spatial dimensions
three should be of order
one which is to say neither very large
nor very small
thus we may reasonably inquire why do
very large numbers
play a fundamental order in our theory
of course that's a central problem many
people talk about the
small value of the cosmological constant
and indeed that's mysterious but
to me equally mysterious and equally
large
uh is the ratio between the mass of the
uh
of the top quark and the mass of the
neutrino
in fact those numbers are that that
that's a number of the same crazy order
of magnitude
yeah that is that is true i haven't and
think about that
on the opposite end uh you ask is the
photon really massless and i think
um maybe 32 years we've we've gotten
more credulity than it is perhaps
massless would you agree i think we can
agree on that yeah so that's an a
plus i'd give that an a plus finally our
neutrino is really massless that's very
interesting very neatly answered
and very satisfactorily answered all too
satisfactory
again it's just uh it's just three
neutrino species
and a three by three mass matrix and
that seems to be the whole picture
despite all the noise about sterile
neutrinos
and uh and anomalies i hope there were
i would i was hoping there were some
anomalies but that don't seem to be any
right has it surprised you that we've
gotten most of the
precise quantity we still don't know the
exact mass of the neutrinos we
we know that there's two different
hierarchies they can adopt but that the
is it surprising that some of the most
quantitative results have not come from
laboratory experiments but from
cosmological limits
amazing and those limits the
cosmological limits
are expected to get stronger and they're
almost
strong enough to pin down which
hierarchy uh which ordering of the
masses is coming that's right yeah
and even with the experiments like i
said earlier one nice thing about the
cosmic microwave background polarization
measurements that i'm involved with
experiments like the simon's observatory
will not only be able to set constraints
or maybe detect primordial gravitational
waves
we'll be able to detect uh the neutrino
hierarchy or at least
you know have a limit on the sum of
neutrino masses which should
illuminate well i'm sure there will be
some
further constraints and that's very very
important
also very uh another indication of of
excitement to come is is the disparity
in experiments measuring the hubble
constant the
public tension yes we talked about that
with adam reese last week on the podcast
we had a
very interesting discussion with him and
wendy friedman
uh who you remember was involved with
the hubble key
project so one of the reasons hubble was
launched was to measure the hubble
constant which makes sense to us
the reason it has a 2.4 meter diameter
mirror is so i could see things like
cepheid variables at great distances it
wasn't known
when it was designed lyman spitzer and
others designing it that it would be
used to measure supernova type 1a
supernova which would then
reveal the presence of dark energy or
accelerated cosmic expansion
but now it's being used by wendy
friedman and her collaborators to look
at
really prosaic objects called red giants
that have very well
understood properties and are not
confusion dominated by other stars and
pixels and outskirts of galaxies
and she's getting a value and consistent
with adam reese
and his team looking at cepheids and and
and even other uh projects that's
wildly inconsistent at the five sigma
level
with the cosmic microwave background
forecast of what the hubble constant
should be
today based on the early expansion of
the universe when the universe is very
simple
and that's a big surprise and and many
people think that's one of the greatest
controversies in
in physics today what what would you say
about that it's uh
i would say it's potentially very
fruitful
if that tension is real it tells us that
we're missing something very important
and that our
standard model of cosmology is flawed
yeah as implications for even things
like the age of the universe when i was
in
high school or college and even graduate
school the value of the hubble parameter
which is the characteristic
inverse of the age of the universe was
unknown at the 100 percent uncertainty
uh level in other words we didn't know
if the universe was 10 billion years old
in 1989 when this book came out or
or if it was 20 billion years old it's a
pretty
pretty wide range and now we know it to
the percent level so cosmology is
becoming more and more
of a precision science but hopefully as
well an accurate science
um you mentioned uh the existence or
lack thereof of magnetic monopoles
and he also uh wrote a poem i guess to
blas cabrera
my old friend at uh at stanford
university who
detected the magnetic monopole on
valentine's day i think
1986 or so and uh
and yet it was never observed again and
and you ask him
beg him to discover monopole 2. so
have you have we made much progress i i
don't know of many experiments
looking for a magnetic monopoles it
seems to be a very
well there have been many searches in
the old days
and yeah they were uniformly negative
and nobody rightly expects that
monopoles will be found but
there's always that possibility of
course and yet
if we if we um do you believe that there
i mean isn't it true that if they if
there exists a magnetic monopole it
would explain the value of the
electronic charge
in direct theory well
i i don't think it would get i don't
think the existence
of the magnetic monopole has anything to
do with evaluating the value
of the electric charge of the electron
no
and uh the last question that you talked
about back then as an open question is
does the
proton live forever and i think uh that
we've gotten a lot more uh clarity about
as time has gone on
a damn long time is what we've learned
yeah
that's right there's not even an
indication
of proton decay right yeah
coming back to it was proton decay that
that
that motivated the imb experiment and
the kamioka experiments
uh and serendipity has led to
many discoveries from these devices they
led to the discovery of
of neutrino oscillations both
atmospheric oscillations and
solar oscillations they led to the
discovery of supernova
consequential discovery of super
supernova neutrinos
that had many consequences and uh
that's contrary to your statement that
why should we spend a lot of money on
who knows right i always say yeah that's
true but it's dangerous to bet on
serendipity
of course yeah the discovery of the cmb
itself uh cosmic microwave background
was discovered serendipitously
the discovery of dark energy or
accelerated expansion that was
serendipitous they thought the universe
was slowing down
that the universe should be decelerating
and in fact they found the example
i remember uh gold gus and goldhab are
calling me
and telling me of this contrary
discovery and what
what could it possibly mean uh he was
they were amazed at what they had fallen
upon
so uh i know we only have a few more
minutes
of your time i just want to be you know
remiss for me not to
talk about views on on on issues that
are very
uh you know modern and current but but
to get your viewpoint on things like
for example the multiverse uh the
anthropic principle
lenny's a big supporter of that your
friend lenny suskin who was on the
podcast yesterday
um what what are your views on things
like the multiverse and are they a part
of
the head you know orthodoxy of physics
should they be
or should they not be well i'm still
of the uh old-fashioned view that uh
the role of the scientist is to deal
with
observable phenomena and by their very
nature the
other universes in the uh
are not observable phenomena so i would
draw a line
at that point and uh
disclaim any interest in multiverses
or other phenomena that are
inconsequential from the point of view
of the observable
observable scientists who observe or
scientists who measure
and uh similarly um where
what do you how would you advise a young
sheldon
nowadays uh if if i'm gonna ask you
things that uh of interest that you
might pursue or recommend pursuit
uh maybe your granddaughters or or
whatever uh if they want to go into
physics and then i'd also ask you what
outside of physics
would is fascinating to you uh for a
young sheldon or
sheldina i don't know um but but to
pursue
oh there's so much in science that
that's uh that ex
is exciting and personally i
i prefer the the useless scientists
sciences
things that i do and things that you do
i think there's
so much more to learn about the universe
uh our observations are
because this remarkable development of
the past
few decades the the fact that as you
mentioned that
that cosmology has become a precise
science
uh is extremely important and uh and
very exciting and there's so much more
to learn you will
i wonder if you will ask uh barry uh
what
the likelihood is that that ligo will be
able to measure
uh the the humble constraint yes i will
i will absolutely yes
and upgrades to ligo they're planning an
upgrade we're going to talk about that
japanese version which is coming online
or has just come
online now there are three facilities
that uh well four facilities the two
american ones
and uh virgo in italy and now
i forget the name of the japanese
which was has the advantage of being
super cool
of the cryogenic device
yes that's right and uh and also with
the addition it's not just
more sensitive but now they can perhaps
go after the polarization
of gravitational waves and perhaps
reveal that they
might you know that there could be you
know departures from the
understood accepted to you know dual
polarization nature
um uh uh also what is the
uh what are your feelings now you know
decades later about grand unification
su-5 looking back what what do you think
its role will be or or will it not have
a role su5 or something like it
in the future uh
i don't know unfort
i told you that one of the things that
gave me the greatest joy
was being confident that some highly
contentious idea like
galman's eightfold way knowing it was
true
and at the same time knowing that others
my colleagues elsewhere did not believe
it
that was a terribly nice feeling and
there were times
uh many times in my life when i felt
that i knew something that other people
don't at this point
i don't know the answers to any of the
questions
i'm waiting for answers
myself the arbitrage of knowledge uh
when you when you know something is
going to be
borne out it allows you to to make uh
make a
make a killing in the marketplace of
ideas what about outside of
physics uh are there things
consciousness um
simulation hypothesis are these things
that physicists
uh talk about when it's physics adjacent
what what things outside of physics
interest you well
how could one not be interested in the
the new advances that are
being made in virology in in developing
vaccines
these vaccines that have the americans
have we
americans have so far been testing the
the uh the two that have been looking
extremely likely to work are based on
absolutely new technologies having to do
with messenger rna
they're not like the old-fashioned uh
things at all i uh they're sufficiently
new to make it
rather difficult to uh predict whether
we can make enough of them to
deal with the american population 20
million by
january is not enough uh that's
that that stuff is very exciting what
they're doing is
extremely exciting i read just yesterday
or the day before
about the uh the the debate about
wolves you surely have read about that
whether we should encourage there to be
more wolves so that they can eat the
uh weaker elk that have elk or deer or
whatever they be
that have developed this uh terrible
uncurable preon
moderated disease before the disease
spreads to humans
now there is absolutely no cure for this
disease
uh even cooking i'm told by the new york
times even
cooking the deer does not kill the
cryons because they never were alive
right
so this this is uh now you're making me
really nervous shelley this this wasn't
part of the deal i
i don't want to like uh have to cancel
my elk dinner tonight but
now you're making uh
what about your salami too that's right
that's right no venison jerky for dinner
um
what about life on other planets if you
had a wager
uh first of all i don't think we know
enough about it but but
do you believe that there is that life
is abundant throughout the universe or
is it more like fermi is to say where is
everybody if there's
well i'm absolutely convinced that there
is life uh
on on other planets than earth
intelligence absolutely convinced
but uh just because of the enormous size
of the uh
visible universe so yes of course maybe
in this galaxy but if not we have
billions of others to choose among
so yes there'll be life out there and
they'll probably be intelligent life as
well
uh well will we have the good fortune
if it is good fortune to encounter such
life that of course i don't know uh this
noise about about some chemical in the
gas of
of some planet venus yeah phosphine uh
like
uh molecule phosphine i think that's
gone away in fact
well actually no it's uh we had on one
of the uh code
uh discoverers sarah seeger across the
uh charles there at
uh mit and her team they uh announced a
rebuttal to their
refutation so it's very intriguing i'm
going to have i'm going to try and have
both teams on the show to debate i did
have a podcast with sarah sieger of mit
about this
they're very confident they say the
confidence level has decreased a little
bit
but it's not enough to for them to
retract the claim whatsoever
so it's a very interesting story about
them
the watery moons out there that may have
some kind of life
on them which uh they may indeed
and uh that's gonna take a lot of money
too
and now would you uh spend billions of
dollars to make uh
a trip to to a to a moon of saturn to
see whether there's
life under the uh under the uh frozen
again my my rule is i don't do single
purpose experiments so if it's just to
see if there's water no
if it's just to see if there's after
other things we can do if we can learn
about extreme
you know uh uh solar system dynamics
planetary formation things like that yes
i might consider such a thing
but if it's just to see if there's water
or ever was water billions of dollars
it's hard to justify but um but uh but
that's very it's very fascinating what
about have you heard of this simulation
there's a possibility of forming
of finding a second form of life on
earth
yes that's right yeah well paul davies
has been a guest in my podcast
he talks about the shadow biosphere and
kind of
using left-handed dna and and and all
sorts of chiral
uh uh creatures etc yes abiogenesis
is very fascinating how did life come
from mere
you know molecules it's it's this is one
of the most exciting question the origin
of life
uh enterprise yeah it's a lot of
people have been working in this well
maybe a lot not a lot
a number of people have been working in
this direction some of the work is very
skilled and very
impressive but we've gotten nowhere as
yet
yeah uh that is that is that is often
the case so of course you know if you
asked
einstein about the prospects to detect
gravitational waves in 1915
he wouldn't have been able to guess that
100 years later a scan 100 years later
to the day almost
um uh last question just about science
and then i'll ask you a couple questions
i ask
everybody uh who comes on the podcast if
you have a couple more minutes shelly is
that okay
sure let's go okay so uh there's a lot
of talk about
uh artificial intelligence uh you're uh
you know across the river neighbor max
teg market mit has written about life
3.0 artificial intelligence super
intelligence uh book by nick balstrom
uh kind of claims that the overwhelming
likelihood
is that we live in some sort of advanced
simulation i wonder what
what do you think about such ideas that
that the moore's law
application and the uh inevitable kind
of
uh artificial supremacy of you know
perhaps by quantum computers that they
will lead to
the likelihood that we are actually
simulated entities that just have this
notion like descartes
used to think about of being a brain in
a vat of really being a brain into that
but in reality we're uh you know we do
we don't have any other choice
no i don't think we're simulations uh
that's
that's the realm of science fiction but
on the other hand
i was amazed when computers first uh
began to win at checkers but i said
they'll never win
win at chess and then they uh they've
demonstrated that
they could win at chess and i said of
course but they'll never
never be able to win it go and then they
demonstrated that they can beat the best
yo players
consistently so uh there's no question
that
that that the uh competence of
computers is growing uh not just
moore's law but something much more
sophisticated with the
methods of machine learning that are now
being used
uh and there are those who feel that
that computers will become sentient and
will become smarter than us certainly if
they do become
sentient they will be smarter than us
and
will this ever happen and does this pose
a danger
comparable to that of pandemics and
nuclear war
and global warming and the answer to
that in
my mind is no
okay shelley you've been so gracious i
just have three more questions
if you'll indulge me the first one
relates to uh something alfred nobel
uh did when he wrote his nobel will this
is my hanukkah gelt
for my kids this is a this is a
chocolate nobel prize unlike the one
i still have a few of those downstairs
so
uh alfred nobel when he wrote his will
he made one of the requirements
uh the betterment of all mankind and so
it wasn't just a material will where he
was giving money
to future intellect such as yourself to
you know discover or invent new things
but they had it benefit mankind
obviously
you know what you discovered doesn't
make a faster
you know high-speed internet but it did
enable the betterment of
of the human spirit to understand the
deepest mysteries of mankind and
of of nature itself i want to ask you
if you were to write an ethical will in
the jewish tradition you're supposed to
live to 120 that's the age
moses lived to so when you're 120 and
you finally
depart this planet what ethical will
would you want to leave what ethical
wisdom not material
but ethical guidance would you want to
give to both your biological children
etc but also your ideological
uh you know ancestors our you know
future
future offspring i don't think i have an
answer for that question
so uh the next question is gonna also go
into the future
and that involves sir arthur c clarke
and you may remember the movie 2001 a
space odyssey
i never saw it but oh okay well there
are these objects that are basically
time capsules and they're meant
they're left by some alien civilization
and it's supposed to last for
millions of years until humanity
discovers it but also is able to
decipher it so in the opening scene
there are some hominids on the planes of
the african savannah and they discover
this time capsule as monolith
and uh and they can't do anything with
it they try to hit it or whatever
but then later there's bound to be one
on the moon and obviously we've advanced
tremendously technologically
between two million years ago in africa
to
go get to the moon so i want to ask you
if you had a billion year long lasting
time capsule
something that was guaranteed what would
you put in it or on it how would you
want to summarize kind of what humanity
is all about or the achievements of
humanity today
maybe it's in physics maybe not uh that
would be kind of something that
future civilizations could discover and
remark about
my hope i can't say prayer because i'm
not religious
is that human society will last
for let's say a thousand years
i'm not optimistic that it will
there are too many outstanding threats
covid is an example of the sort of
threat that we face it will not wipe out
civilization but who knows what the next
pandemic will do
species tend to die off and
there's no reason not to think that our
species will die
off and we can help it with nuclear
weapons
for example and we can help it by doing
this wonderful experiment
the greatest experiment ever performed
is to dig up all of the fossil fuels on
earth and
burn them and see what happens we're
doing that and we're beginning to see
what happens and what's happening
does not suggest to me that there'll be
anyone around in a million years
uh let alone ten thousand years
a thousand years maybe but
i'm much more worried about the
so-called short-term
than uh than deep time
i think it will be a deep time and i
should point out you're a member of the
board of sponsors of the bulletin of the
atomic scientist
where do you rank you know global
warming compared to atomic
um you know holocaust sort of in terms
of existential risks to
existential risks to society as we know
it
a nuclear con a major nuclear
conflagration
uh not just a random bomb shot off by a
pathetic little country but a real
conflagration such as the
uh things we were anticipating between
the soviet union and the united
states would be an end to civilization
as we know it
the climate change
the way we're pointed uh now toward
an inevitable uh 30-foot
rise in the uh in the sea level if
things go as they are uh would certainly
end
uh society as we know it would end the
coastal cities of the united states for
example it would end
the country of bangladesh it would
totally reform
let alone holland it would totally
reform
human society and we're on the road
toward that and uh well what can i say
this my country has not done very much
uh positively over the last four years
in this direction
and then the last question i ask all my
guests shelly
involves not going forward in time now
we're going to go back in time
and it relates to the name of this
podcast so sir arthur c clarke had three
famous laws the first one was any
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic his
second law
was for every expert there's an equal
and opposite expert
and his third law is the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
and that's the name of this podcast and
so i want to ask you when you were 20
years old or 30 years old
what seemed impossible back then but
by virtue of your courage became reality
uh and that uh you would want to
basically give advice to your former
self
i never thought there would be just a uh
a dick tracy phone
for example
such a concept was thoroughly
inconceivable
i remember as a kid wondering if there
would ever be such a thing as television
but impossible things came about and
to to my father skyscrapers were
incredible surprises elevators airplanes
so the change what we have seen in
our lives the development the of the
fact that we all carry around these cell
phones and can talk to
each other for anywhere uh is utterly
amazing so the change that
technology has wrought incredible and
unpredictable changes and
technology will continue to do that i
have no doubt of that
very well well sheldon uh glashow
shelley to uh to some of us i want to
thank you so much for your graciousness
and uh all the inspiration that you
provided i can't recommend this book
highly enough interactions
it's as relevant now uh as it was in the
late 1980s when i first
became aware of it and as i said it only
took me 32 years but i'm
very glad i finished reading it earlier
today uh shelley thank you so much for
spending your time on the into the
impossible podcast i hope we get to meet
in person someday
brian it's been a pleasure if you like
this video please subscribe and check
out other videos and interviews i do
with a multiverse of magnificent minds
into the impossible podcast see you next
time when we go into the impossible
together
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
[Music]
magic
[Music]
you